laser cooling means shining light on
stuff and making it cold now that in
itself sounds like it's completely
backwards because after all you
typically think if you shine light on
something it's gonna get warm so how is
it even possible to shine light on
something and make it cold to cool the
air down means to make those molecules
atoms in the air move more slowly that's
the difference between hot and cold so
how do you make something cold with a
laser well lasers all light pushes on
stuff there's a thing called radiation
pressure white pushes on things what
we've figured out to do over the years
is how to push on atoms in such a way as
to make them slow down
the thing that was perhaps the the
crowning achievement of the early days
of laser cooling was the discovery that
we made in our laboratory that it was
possible to get these atoms colder than
everyone had thought was the limit to
how cold you could get something the
prediction said that we could get down
to temperatures of 240 millionths of a
degree in other words one quarter of one
thousandth of a degree above absolute
zero pretty cold right well in fact we
got a whole lot colder than that and
that was the big breakthrough discovery
that made a whole lot of other things
possible
well all clocks have tickers all of
these tickers have imperfections every
quartz crystal is made a little bit
differently the length of the pendulum
can change a little bit and that changes
how fast it will swing back and forth so
all of these clocks have imperfections
and so women has throughout history been
trying to make these clocks better by
making the tickers be more reliable that
is always have the same ticking
frequency well it turns out that atoms
are the best choice for making tickers
that always take it the same frequency
even atoms have their imperfections
temperature means that the atoms are
moving with a certain velocity having a
certain kinetic energy the hotter the
gas is the faster the atoms are moving
it's not so easy to measure the ticking
frequency of something that's whizzing
around at the speed of sound and that's
the problem
that everybody was facing with atomic
clocks was that the atoms were moving at
approximately the speed of sound and it
wasn't so easy to measure the ticking
frequency so we said let's cool them
down using lasers so they're going more
slowly and that'll make it easier to
measure the ticking frequency and you
can make better clocks when I started
doing laser cooling the very best clocks
were accurate to a part in 10 to the 13
so that's one part divided by one with
13 zeros after it that's the fractional
error in how good that clock wah sounds
incredible right but today those clocks
are a couple in 10 to the 16 almost
three orders of magnitude better and
that has been made possible because of
laser cooling
I suppose that young children are
curious about everything and very early
my curiosity tended toward curiosity
about science my parents got me a
microscope when I was very young maybe
six years old and I remember looking at
all kinds of things around the house
with this microscope I remember
collecting various household chemicals
and fluids to mix together which was my
homemade chemistry set and in addition I
was doing all the other things that kids
do climb trees and scurry up and down
cliffs and collect huckleberries in the
woods but there was always a lot of
physical activity and a lot of that
physical activity for me involved doing
things that that related to science
looking at stuff being Karia curious
about the natural world
that's a really interesting question and
sadly the answer isn't simple the simple
answer is no but now I've got to explain
wha here I'm saying that the answer is
no the answer is that every process for
cooling either also introduces the
possibility that you can introduce some
extra energy into the system you see
cooling means taking energy out and
heating means putting energy in but in
order to take energy out then it turns
out that you open the door for energy to
go in take laser cooling laser cooling
takes the energy out by having an atom
coming along and then a photon hits the
atom and slows the atom down but then
that photon has to go someplace and when
that photon is shot out by the atom the
atom recoils and more energy goes in so
there's a balance between the cooling
the heating and you can try to make that
balance work more and more in your favor
but you can never make it work a hundred
percent cooling and no heating so that's
one of the reasons why you don't expect
to ever get to absolute zero on the
other hand what does it mean to be at
Absolute Zero it means that all the
thermal motion stops well I can take one
atom and I can take as much energy out
of it as possible so that it's in what
we would call the ground state the
lowest possible state of energy is it
absolute zero not really because in
order to be at Absolute Zero I really
have to have a whole bundle of things I
can't really talk easily about the
temperature of a single object
I should really talk about a whole
ensemble and if I do that with a whole
bunch of atoms what's gonna happen is
maybe if I'm lucky maybe 99% of them are
gonna be in the ground state and then 1%
isn't so it's not absolute zero I can't
come up with any procedure that is gonna
say a hundred percent of the time this
atoms gonna end up in the ground state
and that's what I would need to be able
to claim that I'd really got into
absolute zero but on the other hand I
can get so close to absolute zero that
for many experiments
it's basically absolute zero for all
practical purposes but not for all
experiments and we're constantly working
on trying to make things colder because
for some experiments it really matters
that we're not quite there
well my reaction to hearing about the
Nobel Prize was one of shock and
disbelief in fact I can remember very
very well when this happened I was
attending a meeting in California
meeting of the American Physical Society
and the optical Society of America
meeting jointly out in California in
Long Beach California
and the day before the prizes were
announced a number of us were sitting
around after the scientific sessions
were over speculating about who was
going to get the Nobel Prize that year
and believe me nobody brought up my name
so later that night well it was the
middle of the night that I got a call in
my hotel room to the effect that I had
shared the Nobel Prize with claude
cohen-tannoudji and Steve Chu came as a
complete shock
my life changed dramatically it's very
difficult for me to keep up with all of
the invitations that I get to speak
about my work the size of my research
group has has grown that's made it
possible for me to be involved in more
and more new kinds of physics but it's
made it harder and harder for me to be
intimately familiar with all the things
that are going on so there's a kind of a
tension between the joy and doing lots
of new things and the desire to
understand them better and better
another thing that I never would have
imagined would have been one of the
results of becoming a Nobel laureate is
that I ended up meeting people who are
actually famous so you know people say
oh you're a Nobel laureate you must be
famous no nobody remembers you know
outside of the field in which you're
working nobody remembers who won the
Nobel Prize even a couple years ago but
as a result of being a Nobel laureate I
get invited to two things where I've met
people who are actually famous but one
of the people that I have met who has
been most charming is dr. Ruth
Westheimer she lives in New York City
and I see her probably about once a year
and she's just a wonderfully warm and a
genuine person just just just a joy to
know as a friend
well first of all I should say that I
I'm not particularly comfortable with
being described as a religious person
because somehow I have this image in my
mind of of somebody who's has very
proper and and prim and follows all
sorts of rituals and stuff and and I
like rather to describe myself as a
person of faith and clearly I don't
believe that science has made belief in
God obsolete or else I wouldn't describe
myself as a person of faith I believe
that certain ways of interpreting
certain scriptures have been made
obsolete by science but that in no way
makes religious faith or belief in God
obsolete it just requires what I would
consider to be a different outlook a
maturation of religious faith but if we
look at the history of religious faith
as told in the scriptures and as seen
throughout history I think the entire
history of faith has been one of a
maturation of that faith I see it not so
much as people becoming more mature in
their faith but God challenging people
to become more mature to get a clear
understanding of what God wants for
humankind and I think God is always
pushing us to be better than what we are
okay so there's two ways of answering
that question by and large science and
religion deal with different kinds of
questions science deals with questions
about how do things come to be the way
they are how should I think about the
way things are how shall I organize my
understanding of the way things behave
whereas religion deals with questions
like how should I behave toward my
fellow human creatures what should my
relationship be to God how should I
understand the ultimate origins of this
world in this universe in which we live
these are very different kinds of
questions but sometimes the areas that
science addresses and the areas that
religion addresses can overlap so I
don't ascribe to the idea of science and
religion as being non-overlapping
magisteria as they've sometimes been
described but I also will say that by
and large they deal with different kinds
of questions but there are ethical
questions that might involve things like
medical ethics or environmental
questions where you have to understand
the science in order to be able to make
good ethical decisions that are guided
by your religious principles so there's
always going to be places where science
and religion are going to come to bear
on the same kinds of
all the time in fact it's one of the
greatest things about being a scientist
is that you're continually surprised
nature is so much more clever than we
are that we never understand the secrets
that nature has to has to offer but
little by little we learn more and more
but every time we go into the laboratory
we're surprised
I work in an area physics atomic physics
where the basic principles as far as we
know the basic principles were pretty
much understood in the 1930s maybe some
details were worked out in the 40s and
50s but we are still surprised every day
by the results of these things so so in
spite of the fact that some people might
say well there's nothing new we're
surprised every day and the the things
we learn were things that nobody
imagined that things would work this way
so for example let's go back to this
example about laser cooling everybody
thought they understood how cold you
could get things using laser cooling and
the problem was a simple enough problem
you can write down the proof and in a
few minutes as to how cold is possible
to get something and we got it
eventually 200 times colder for for one
particular atom then the theory said was
possible why well because the situation
was a little bit more complicated
remember I said that physicists like to
make a problem really simple that's the
physicists way of looking at a problem
well Einstein once said a problem should
be made as simple as possible but no
simpler and sometimes you make a mistake
and you leave out some really important
stuff usually when you do that it makes
things worse this was a case where
putting in the complications made things
work better nobody would have guessed
that that was gonna happen
I can't imagine anybody sitting down and
thinking okay we're gonna figure out how
laser cooling works and coming up with
what actually happens we had to do the
experiments first nature showed us what
was what was gonna happen and then
clever people figured out what was
really going on these kinds of surprises
happen to us
all the time